all right we have been watching the
trial of kyle rittenhouse and it's been
riveting the entire day of watching the
five and great to have everybody here
judge jeanine geraldo jesse waters and
greg gutfeld let's go to the judge and
get your take well
i was just checking
how long after the two murders and the
uh the one assault or attempted murder
the charges were filed because this
video the drone and all of the other
information that's been brought together
took a while to put together this d.a
charged rittenhouse within
48 hours
so the d.a never really looked into
whether or not there was a possibility
of self-defense he just immediately
indicted him and what you're seeing
today is a d.a who was reacting to the
the the whole scenario of what we were
doing in a post-george floyd world in an
area where jacob blake had just been
shot you've got a young guy who was a
you know a new cpr he was a police
explorer he was some kind of fireman
cadet he was a good kid he went there to
clean up the the
graffiti on the buildings he has he has
exemplified on that witness stand what
every defendant should learn to do and
that is to speak clearly directly he
stops exactly where he should stop he
doesn't add any further information he
listens exquisitely to the questions and
he you know there isn't even a need on
the part of the defense attorney to
object to this prosecutor who is so
desperate so out of control that he's
even got the judge going through the the
roof in that courtroom the bottom line
here is that this kid has established
that when he shot uh rosenbaum the first
victim he was in fear of for his own
life when he shot the second guy huber
he was in fear legitimately and
reasonably of his own life and when he
shot gross christ the third guy who
didn't die for which he's being charged
with attempted murder he had legitimate
grounds for which to use deadly physical
force so now the question is whether or
not the prosecutor can prove now because
the burden of proof has shifted beyond a
reasonable doubt that it was not
self-defense he can't do it
yesterday geraldo you said that you
thought that this trial might not even
go to the point where you have the
defendant take the witness stand but he
did and perhaps that might have been the
best thing that he could have done for
himself it was something that i would
not have recommended putting the
defendant on the witness stand is always
problematic it's a toss of the dice more
bad things can happen than good but this
kid has stood his ground
you know this is a self-defense case did
he reasonably believe that his life was
in danger and was the force he used to
defend himself appropriate and uh it
just seems to me that the kid is dying
he's a dopey kid with the hero complex
uh you know he shouldn't have been there
shouldn't have had the ar-15 on the
street and all the rest of it but i
think he walks i tell you the truth i
don't i don't see how they touch them on
the murder cases the most serious
charges uh you know the other one uh
what is it a recklessly endangering uh
you know i i think there's a reasonable
possibility that aside from the
possession of the weapon as a minor
uh you know i think that the written
house is going to go go ahead
well first of all i don't think he's a
dopey kid just because he isn't mr cool
from new york city doesn't make him a
dopey kid okay this kid practiced cpr
trained he was a police explorer he was
a firefighter seventeen-year-old guy
that you know that takes an ar-15 to a
neighborhood you know what you don't
know what it's like in that part of the
country or maybe you do i do you do you
live there
it's a part of life for them and you
know what the charge is for possession
of that weapon nine months because he's
under 18. i think that's only one let's
not conflate the issues here that's a
good kid that is the kind of kid who can
grow up and have a moral core jesse
earlier today the defense did move and
asked for a mistrial because of the
prosecutor
prosecutors a joke not only has he
exhibited prosecutorial misconduct he
coached a witness to lie and got caught
cold i've never seen anything like this
guy it's now illegal to
defend yourself if someone is assaulting
you chasing you grabbing your weapon
shooting firearms over your head and
then aiming a revolver at your skull
this prosecutor says you can't
defend yourself that is insane this all
started with jacob blake
the prosecutor's office corrupt democrat
district attorneys release a falsely
edited piece of footage to make it look
like this was a cold-blooded racial
execution attempt when in fact blake was
a bad guy who was a rapist and had a
knife and was a danger to the police
officers and those people in that car
that only didn't come out until later
but at that point that inflamed such
hostility in the streets this is a very
tender moment remember this is just
after the situation we saw in in in
minneapolis
so all of a sudden people start looting
and rioting for three state days
millions of dollars in damage
politicians basically told the police to
stand down they weren't doing anything
to stop this unfortunately some of these
small business owners had to call in
help
and this guy listen to the call i agree
shouldn't had a gun probably shouldn't
be there but that's what happens when
you treat police like garbage and
politicians tell him not to defend
law and order all right so he gets out
there clear self-defense everybody that
sees the footage knows that what do they
do media comes out and smears this guy's
a white supremacist joe biden comes out
during the campaign puts out a tweet
linking donald trump says white
supremacy with a picture of written
house with the ar that's slander
straight up and then this corrupt
prosecutor goes out and throws a slew of
nasty charges at this guy because he
wants to run for d.a he's already run
for d.a once this guy's got political
aspirations this is an axis of evil this
is prosecutors the press and politicians
conspiring to create violence create a
deadly situation and then when a deadly
violent situation happens they want a
scalp
of this kid and that is that is really
corrupt i just want to show that one
thing we have the sound from the judge
scolding the prosecution then we're
going to go to great dream them
i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives
well i'll leave it at that
so i don't know what you're up to get
brazen with me you
know very well that an attorney can't go
into these types of areas when the judge
has already ruled without asking outside
the presence of the jury to do so so
don't give me that
so that happened that happened earlier
today greg and then there is just
another angle on this and that is the
media coverage at the time and since
and if there's any sort of revisiting of
that
yeah
as
jesse pointed out the media coverage of
the jake and jacob blake thing led to
this
in so many ways because what they did
was they excused the rampant violence
they cheered the reduction of police and
what did that do it creates a void who
fills that void well sometimes thugs do
but other times well-meaning citizens
who have had enough that is a story that
is old as time that when there is no
police you become the policeman hence
the reason why you have cops but i've
learned a lot from this prosecutor
number one you have to let someone beat
you over the head with a skateboard if
you defend yourself that's on you you
should never shoot a guy pointing a gun
at you because he hasn't shot you yet
and remember that he made that very
clear
you know he hasn't shot you yet and when
when a guy comes at you with a gun up
close
he probably won't shoot you because he
could have shot you maybe 10 feet
earlier however he probably would have
had a better chance to kill you up close
but that never would have happened
because he would have done it already
and some but the bottom line is somebody
pointing a gun at you is not enough for
self-defense you must be shot first what
the bottom line and and uh jesse nailed
it
ridden house was doing a policeman's job
because he could no re no longer rely on
the state or the politicians to provide
cover protection for the police the city
was burning and going to hell unabated
so this kid rightly or wrongly
acting probably on his own instincts
felt that he could help i love jeffrey
toobin's take today where he says
rittenhouse is lucky that uh he's not on
trial for being an idiot
and this is a guy who should
yeah he should be really thinking about
a concealed permit
before uh going after tubing you know
what i'm saying yeah but uh
i think that what you're going to see
now is if the media if the media
deliberately blocks this information
from coming out and instead because for
example you never would have known
that uh gage had pointed the gun
at this guy if you've been following the
media's coverage of this therefore if he
is acquitted you're gonna have the same
thing where people go oh my god white
guy white guy acquitted uh he could do
whatever he wants even though he shot
white people doesn't matter because our
because our media is interested in the
racial divide more than anything they're
gonna make it about race rex chapman
already did it on twitter
and then what's gonna happen is you're
gonna have uh the activist class egged
on by the media once again at cnn saying
you know it is time to scream and yell
and yes restorative justice can take the
shape of looting and arson but that's
because we are now in the business of
misinforming the public to create
conflict we have a montage that our team
put together of some of the media
coverage if he could rule that for us
please
to defend the actions of a 17 year old
man who killed two protesters one of
which was armed with a skateboard
um and the last time i checked i don't
think a skateboard could kill someone a
17 year old kid from out of state a boy
from out of state
drives up to the state with an ar-15
around his neck
shoots and kills a couple of people uh
shooting wildly running around uh acting
like uh rent-a-cop and it's not good
that a 17-year-old vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people in this guy so the media
continue uh hellmann uh the media
continued
to i mean basically baskin glory i guess
is the one of these things
as the judge goes forward with this with
this request from the defense for a
mistrial is that a possibility
you know i don't think at this point the
judge is going to grant the request for
a mistrial but i do have something to
say about the judge and the way the
judge acted in this case the judge lost
it and he lost it for good reason what
you've got is the prosecution crossed
the line that is is as old as the
constitution where you have a right to
not incriminate yourself and the and the
prosecution is trying to make this kid
someone who is not entitled to the right
to remain silent you know from every tv
show you ever watch you have a right to
remain silent but this prosecutor is
saying this is the first time you talked
about it since you since this thing
happened as if therefore you're not
entitled to have the right to remain
silent and everyone in their mind when
they go into the jury room is going to
say gee i wonder he had to think it all
through and work it all through that's a
fundamental mistake by the prosecution
so when the judge says why would you
even do that i can't figure out why you
would do it the prosecution wants to
push a mistrial here because the
prosecution knows they're losing this
kid is one of the best witnesses i've
seen on the witness stand without a
doubt he has an uncanny sense for what
to say and when to stop
and he's fighting for his life we're
going to go back to the trial in just a
moment we're getting one more comment
from geraldo and jesse geraldo you first
the defense does not want a mistrial at
this stage the defense is winning this
is not this is not a domestic terrorist
it is clear that the image that was
built is is built on on false legos that
this is a 17 year old kid again i go
back a dopey mistake hero complex i can
save my community i'm uh you know
i'm just like all those great people
people that join that join the military
maybe they're usually 17 maybe so maybe
they want to help they want to help
their society stand that i am i am
announcing that i believe he's going to
be acquitted yeah this this the
prosecution missed the mark the
prosecution tried every dirty trick they
possibly could the facts don't work for
the prosecution the kid
was reasonable in his use of force and
deadly force and that's what it's about
geraldo don't you think that once the
d.a had the drone information had the
information from the witnesses they
should have at least offered a plea here
because the d.a jumped in 48 hours you
indict in a case like this you don't
even know the facts in 48 hours there
should have been some recognition that
this was a loser case
i wonder at what point right the defense
knew that they were going to put the kid
on i want to know if they led the
prosecution down the primrose path to
then whack them with a kid that was
impenetrable from the point of view of
this lame prosecutor we've known for a
long time that the drone video has been
out there
but whether the kid was going to
testify i didn't know the kid was going
to well we don't obviously you don't
have to tell anybody you're kidding
let's get jesse go ahead jesse the
montage we showed of the press
that was so sinister
they have lost control of information in
america they used to have total control
so he used to go on tv and lie they used
to
you look at the headlines covering this
story it's almost like they're watching
a different trial than the rest of the
country we have the internet now we see
all different angles of footage we can
actually watch testimony live and they
are trying to sell a lie to their
audience because maybe their audience
isn't watching or maybe the audience
wants to be lied to can i say one
because they're not interested in the
truth one thing
we have to be careful not to be rooting
for the kid you know what i mean
that's why and they should be rooting
for that too
sideways from their narrative you move
the narrative towards the truth they
have not shouldn't have been there but
they shouldn't have threatened it with
their pistols they shouldn't have
whacked his head with the skates this is
clear self-defense or everybody i i am
saying the reason
you know it's funny
it's hard not to personalize this but i
keep thinking like okay you know they
keep saying he went straight straight uh
across state lines it's actually pretty
close to where he lives it's where he
works right it's where he works his
father lives in kenosha
got it god i know that what i'm saying
is if i were 17
and my community was being destroyed and
i had and i was there and i had these
skills and again i'm 17 and i i am an
optimistic hopeful person and i'm
watching my community be destroyed which
would i hide in my house i don't know
what i would do but i would definitely
be outside and i would definitely go and
see what i could do i don't know if i
would have a gun because california it's
different but i would have been and for
the most part as he's testified and as
witnesses have testified he was putting
out fires and delivering medical aid
that's what he was up to that was the
least believable part of his testimony
no really well because witnesses
testified to the same thing they have
videotape of him cleaning graffiti and
witnesses saying that he applied medical
aid to that he explained and he
testified to that as well we're going to
just take a very quick break we'll have
more of the five coming right up
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else